last hour we were talking about the
movie Copland and Pauly watched it
yesterday two-a-days watched it as well
and then we asked the question is it a
good movie or is it a great movie and it
was nineteen ninety-seven she had some
big stars in there it de niro Stallone
who else did you have in there Harvey
Keitel and Michael Rapaport was in the
movie so I said the Fritzi i said reach
out to Michael see if he'll join us here
and Michael joins us from Philadelphia
Michael what were the reviews when that
that movie came out in 1997 what was the
reaction to Copland home first of all I
good and you should said you needed me
rose said the world I'm tell and then we
should have said and we had the biggest
star on the phone I would have
appreciated this you introduces Michael
Michael I called you first i didn't call
dinero I didn't call Stallone I didn't
call Harvey Keitel I called you no
reviews the reviews on the soul or they
were good they weren't incredible I
think there was so much hype remember
they had a press conference for the
movie before we even started shooting
there was so much hype in the show all
that movie deals in a tan disclosed
going to gain weight and he is going to
be sorted is returned to his sort of
rocky issues so i think the soul you
know sort of underwhelmed um you know at
the box office and in fact good reviews
it didn't take frequent user did already
astra attention and this is at the
height of the miramax you know lately
really should've you know how they're
learning as far as independent shows so
i mean i think people like it i just
don't think they love won't watch it
like i said i think is darker and more
complicated show that i think it was it
was a sort of advertised to be most
intense actor of that group ii good
question you know the most intense actor
of any sort out intense De Niro Harvick
I telling this is no walk in the park uh
in fact my face and
the bottom of the George W did so in
between 3am at 6pm he did it three am at
6am he did it in the most loving way he
smacked my face I appreciate it I was
flattered to have my things max this
wasn't in the scene come I love horny by
the way so I understood why he did it in
hindsight he had Peter Berg was also in
that form of radiator and then it was
probably on today I'm ice cream are all
Swiss not the most you know Joe Hey Joe
via guy so there was a half of them i
think the navy i clicked with the mix
while of coral bonded with the most
worst alone um because i think he was
sort of an out an outsider on that on
that bed and and you know and i just i
love to wrestle and walking mean so much
to me so to be on the set with him and
sort of have all access to all my rocky
questions he was games would oh that's
cool it was a great experience a great
set and a lot of excitement who were you
up against for that role be honest with
you I don't think I was and I'm saying
this I wish I had much more jobs like
this I don't think I was up against
anybody I think they were sort of
picking the people they wanted the
producer Kerry Wood and III had a good
relationship with him and the wine
season they came to me and and at first
I was a little reluctant to do it I
don't know why I thought I was clear
this up against supposed to do things
when you're in the twenties and you know
and you know you everything is working
you don't have any twists or turns your
ankles on but I was like that I mean I
couldn't believe that I just wish this
asset when I was there with you know
anytime I couldn't I couldn't believe it
because I was really having a lower body
experience from being very professional
and focused at the fantastic in it the
scene in which they try to drown you how
many times did you do that soon so they
can't wait to do it why I don't I don't
know why RV and peter berg why date they
wanted to talk soon after day I don't
know why they said we've got it on the
fourth tape and then either do x57 cakes
and they like a suicide I don't know if
you really want to
you know like really see what I was like
if I had like some bills just skill
under the scope um we did a handful of
times everybody was clean special I
actually fell off the balcony of that
pool when we were shooting it will have
you in studio here soon i know you're
shooting in philadelphia and you know
maybe during basketball season we can
talk about your new nix the super the
other super team in the NBA Michael well
yeah I mean why do you feel the other
super team let's just take the only
super team in the NBA Cleveland plum in
the state who cares who will you
acquired who I don't know who that is
New York Knicks are the only super team
around so I would love to come back I'm
in Philadelphia shoot this out this
teaches you campaign with Snapple and
and then I love your show I'm such a
huge fan noise and I mean it must feel
like you don't feel like okay I mean the
respect you talk about holy waters start
and then boom the biggest one calls you
off faucet it must feel great being used
and I'm other's houses I'm a humongous
fan and I'll Mike I gotta go I got I got
Kai tell on hold here I gotta go Michael
okay great yes sorry that's Michael
Rapaport the movie Coplin 1997 the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience